[Music]
as you can see i'm at gina's house and
the reason why i'm at gina's house is
because big mood is getting a new set
and now we're going to be having our set
here at gina's place that was nibbler
her cat meowing just now he's so
freaking cute um but gina's not home
actually she uh gave me the door code to
her house so casey and i are here to set
up for the set the other day we went to
our old like the first set so like two
sets ago so the previous set was nikki's
house and the previous set to that was
at a studio and so we went to the studio
we picked up our old couches the pink
couches
feels like the last of the stuff that we
left here so thank you bryce for holding
it for us for all this time yeah so now
we're gonna be doing all like we're
picking all this stuff up so then we can
set it up at gina's house
and so now we're setting everything else
up so let me show you this is what we
got going on so we're setting up in this
room
so yeah gina's always had this like
spare room never really did anything
with it we're like oh that could be the
set like we can just have this set live
there now casey and i have been in
charge of setting all this up and so you
can see the two couches i put blankets
over the couches because this kitty boy
is here and also a dog lives here so
just the cleanliness of the couches i
put the blankets over and this is the
rug that i got for the set you guys
remember a little bar carts there and
yeah like we just purchased like more
equipment so you can really have this
set live here forever so i'm gonna be
putting up this wallpaper today and i'm
kind of intimidated because i'm not in
like my typical physique you know like
i'm 32 weeks pregnant now and
i feel it like i really feel 32 weeks
pregnant so i'm kind of like a little
bit dreading this but at least i have
casey here to help me i also got some
blackout curtains for this window here
and also to cover this entrance exit
whatever to the living room but the cool
thing is about
here there's a door here
so
we're gonna be using like whenever we're
filming here we're gonna be closing the
door whole bunch of stuff we're doing
here yeah what are you up to setting up
lights the goal is to make this the best
big mood set ever yeah every time we
reset the set or we give it a new home
new face yeah we're always trying to
give it the best
set moving forward so this will be the
best big new set ever yeah i love that
ambition that that uh manifestation i
love it oh yeah and i also bought this
plant so we're gonna have a plant right
here covering that wooden door i got a
vision and hopefully it all works it all
comes together because in the previous
sets it's always been like all four of
us really working together and making it
happen but for this set i saw me baby
well working with
i meant the set design you're working
equipment oh yeah so like i gotta do all
this and i also have to find like decor
pieces to fill up that's that shelf
there i don't know there's still a lot
to do and by the way we're filming so
today is what monday today's monday
we're filming this saturday so we
totally left it for last minute because
we had a whole month to set this up but
the holidays and all that got crazy and
then we're also going to be doing
another shoot like a two-day shoot in
february and then that's gonna be it
until after i have the baby and we're
gonna do some zoom sessions so you can
look forward to some zoom sessions
because jess can't fly over during tax
season because you know she's a full cpa
now and all that and then in may it's
gonna be fun though because we're
planning our may shoots like a two-day
shoot to be at nikki's place so we're
totally doing the sisterhood of the
traveling podcast you guys we're gonna
be taking all this equipment to nikki's
place in vegas in may to shoot then so
that's gonna be exciting but in the
meantime let's focus on this set let's
get
wallpaper up here let's get these
curtains up there let's do it
[Music]
he likes to plant
[Music]
look at that so what are we doing now
wallpaper time time has been
very much looking forward to
all right time for a coffee break i'm
not looking forward to putting up that
wallpaper either tiff why can't things
be easier faster and just less
complicated well enter commenteer coffee
thanks to comments here for sponsoring
today's video like putting up wallpaper
i find making a good cup of coffee very
very complicated there's just a lot of
steps that i don't want to take in the
morning to make a good cup of coffee i
used to do the french press but i found
the mocha pot to be slightly better than
a french press either way you still have
to put the ground coffee beans into the
mocha pot or into the french press and
the worst part is yet to come the
cleanup cleaning up ground coffee beans
is not fun either call me lazy but i'm
looking for something even more simpler
than that enter cometier it's not like
any other coffee brand it's barista
quality coffee brewed through science
and flash frozen to lock in flavor and
freshness in the world's first 100
curbside recyclable aluminum capsule
commenter partners with the best
regional specialty coffee roasters they
grind and brew to perfection to lock in
the freshness for a delicious cup of
coffee all you have to do is pop open a
frozen capsule and add eight ounces of
hot water and if you want iced coffee
defrost the capsule then pour it over
cold milk and ice for delicious iced
coffee double cheers
oh those are good cups of coffee and
just to let you in on a secret i've
actually stopped drinking caffeine all
together so these are decafs and let me
tell you for deep calf coffees these are
delicious check out commentary they're
super convenient and it's high quality a
lot of times for the sake of convenience
i sacrifice the taste but no more of
that with commentary and for a limited
time commenter has a special offer for
fans of the channel you can get 20 off
your first purchase plus free shipping
when you click my link that's 10 free
cups of coffee and over 30 off and the
best thing yet no coffee grinds to clean
that's it anyways
coffee break is over time to get back to
that wallpaper all right so we were
making really good progress up until now
yeah and this is literally the part of
the wall where our faces are gonna be so
it's really important that it's not all
messed up but now there's like getting
all crooked and air bubbles and i'm like
why do you do this to me why like i we
were breezing all the way up until this
point where it literally matters and now
it's like oh why
you know my perfection my perfectionist
ass is not gonna let this fly i'm gonna
make it perfect true you know my half
ass is like you know what the camera's
not probably not gonna pick it up so
all right no big deal a big deal it's
really big it's huge it's it's huge well
it's not going to be as big of a deal as
this guy over here
guy
or girl
you're so convinced that it's a boy
because i'm so convinced of the boy that
now you're calling the baby a boy watch
it be a girl oh look at this
literally everything here is fine except
theirs for why
for why when i put wallpaper up
sometimes i have to go backwards to fix
my mistakes and then move forward so
it's like a metaphor of life you know
beautiful you have to look at your past
and
heal those wounds in order for you to
move forward in a healthy way
all thinking all deep while i'm putting
up wallpaper this is exactly the
activity you would do to have those deep
thoughts that's true it's very like a
meditation kind of activity yeah that's
why i like cooking when i cook by myself
i end up going to very deep thoughts and
i really appreciate those those moments
and then you know what's weird every
time i focus on things i concentrate did
you catch that no
my my freaking nose always gets runny
where i'm like is my brain leaking
because i'm thinking too hard
it's so dark i need tissue but i'm just
gonna use this i'm already prepping for
it when the baby's here like i'm being
the baby now right now like using using
clothes to like is that white house we
have a baby you just want to close the
white things uh or like the bib or
whatever
yeah i don't know it's so nasty i can't
really just do that in front of you all
you guys i don't care about doing in
front of casey because i do it all the
time you guys just saw my nasty side put
my boogers in my shirt and you know what
i'm so annoyed at myself because i made
a checklist of all the things i should
bring to this house in order to prep the
set and the most important thing i
didn't bring which is my wallpaper kit
where it's like it had like the straight
thing and then the exacto knife thing
and then the cutting thing it would have
made this way easier i forgot it
and luckily gina had scissors because if
not then i really couldn't do this at
all make do what we got oh that's so
ugly it's right in the middle too
relax let it go no big deal right now
all right guys we are back at the set
and look at that we installed the
wallpaper the second layer and i pin
striped it gold all around so the
pinstriping you won't see on camera but
we see it with our own eyeballs and i
wanted us to enjoy what we look at and
also if we're doing like stories or
whatever it looked pretty with the gold
yeah and then we got some yellow pillows
in here i kind of wanted them more gold
but whatever we're gonna just have to
make do with what we got and then we got
a little bit of plants really excited
for the girls to see the full product
the final reveal i really hope that they
like it
hola
everybody
oh you look so good your makeup looks
great sorry gina you don't look so great
no way
you guys look bad we can't have an ugly
friend go ahead
yeah so gina will not be joining us for
this shoot because why work said that
someone tested positive
from yesterday's shoot for what aids
for coven oh so they want us to isolate
as much as possible when i got that text
this morning this morning after i
literally after both of us flew in yes
for this shoot and it's the first time
it's at gina's house exactly he's not
even gonna be in any of the videos we
filmed today now you have to quarantine
no i can lock myself in my room and
listen to them all have fun in here i'm
not scared of her because i already
recovered from omicron so i'm like i
might go hang out with her later but i'm
waiting until you leave yeah we have to
wait till i leave
yeah we can't get the baby infected or
even nikki cause she's staying at her
house i got all of them i
i want to see your reactions to this set
do this the last time you decorated this
set well because this time i feel
special about this yeah i i worked hard
well it's because the last time too we
all kind of worked on it and this one i
i kind of did
my pictures and stuff i didn't work it
was in my house so i saw it you guys
worked on it yeah you reacted to it i
was like what a cool couch
i saw like a mid-way picture yeah i did
i did give you guys a photo of it
already but my reaction wouldn't be that
grand probably because i kind of already
saw them damn it i actually never brand
no actually that's true never
same reaction
your audience is gonna be like just so
whatever it is
you're not the real one cause you don't
put it on i'm gonna fake it
i'll fake it for both of us no don't
fake it i'm really good are you sure you
don't want me to fake it no i want you
to be really
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right here we go you guys open the
curtains there we go
is that the real one i know i can't even
tell oh my god it looks so good you like
it
looks so good this looks way better i
think honestly and this is not my fake
this is numb i'll give you my fake one
after this okay but um
this is i'm not even joking
this is my favorite set that we've just
i'm glad that gina let you put wallpaper
on her wall well it's a peel and stick i
didn't even ask for permission oh you
didn't even know
i love how the blue matches the blue yay
[Applause]
yeah i'm glad you guys like it i love it
good job tiff yeah that was awesome
it's like a good thank you stuff that we
already had before but like yeah and
like i don't know kind of where it's
like we we collected yeah over the years
it kind of goes together yeah and this
wallpaper it just looks way better than
the green wall yeah right
that's true i really wanted texture for
our walls for the longest time
for the look at this photo is just like
so prominent
it's like they died and that's the
option
we need to put a candle like they all
went on a plane together
oh no
oh yeah this is casey's little quarter
now yeah are you happy with yourself so
i've upgraded my i have a real chair
yeah yeah it's not like a stool we're
legit now yeah yeah you did a good job
thank you good job yeah
why'd you like it oh you wanna see my
fake one now oh yeah yeah what's your
big one
reset
back to one i'll give you a few samples
okay okay
okay
and
action
[Music]
wow
oh my god
[Laughter]
okay take three i'm starting to
understand why nicki never made it in
hollywood
[Laughter]
i was from multicam that was okay
yeah that was right that's multicam yeah
this is christine this is a single
camera okay this is
all right
where i put myself oh my gosh
did you do something
you did something entertaining
that was great i like that one
that's so funny all right now we're
gonna get started
thank you for joining us on this journey
of creating a new big mood set
[Music]
why is it blue well i told her they
didn't know the gender so make it
generic she said blue is gender neutral
she said i feel the color palette i said
the mother likes teal
she's like tiffany's
cookies
blue
cute
a little rattle
you're so nice oh look at this baby
outfit oh little onesie this is so cute
you want to eat one right now thank you
you know what's funny earlier you're
like why did the delivery guy say your
name saying nikki's name and i was like
you're getting mad dude i was like why
it's seriously creepy why can't you
remember that
remember what is wrong with your brain
was an accident just happening
i was like it
oh
and then gina came and she's like hey i
was like no
i thought i ordered something and i did
it
it was during the holiday season it was
like right between right after christmas
and before new year's and it was just in
the middle of the weekend
i know texas is vegas and then gina was
in yeah she went to missouri or yeah
fly over one of
baby time
[Music]
congratulations on the new crotch
goblins
[Music]
we love you
can't wait to meet a little astronaut oh
so sweet
i want to hug someone
[Laughter]
you're going to lonely ladies love you
all right so it's midnight now we
really took our sweet time today to
finish these four episodes and also film
a whole bunch of ads right now jess is
leaving yes i have to go back and
get to my hotel room
but this is the last time we're we're
all going to be together until may
and the longest we've ever not seen each
other yeah those three will see each
other next month yeah we'll be here this
girl in february but then yeah they go
off after that though you guys might not
see each other in homemade after
february yeah maybe unless you fly like
i'll be a mom already i know this baby
will be three months old the next time i
see you jess kid in here you're gonna
get up easy it'll actually
we'll know who they are and their name
and everything people know everything
about you
yeah
for three months
[Laughter]
oh it's so weird
she's mocking you exactly
you know what don't even call me i don't
want you to call me
okay bye
[Music]
you